it was seen as a delicate Balancing Act
German Chancellor Olive Schultz had to
perform during his meeting with Chinese
Premier Lee Chung protect Germany's
large business interests in China at a
time of growing Western criticism and
distrust towards its largest trading
partner
I've once again appealed to the Chinese
government to use its influence on
Russia in this war even more strongly as
a permanent member of the U.N security
Council China has a special
responsibility we should work together
on this in the G20 as well therefore it
is important that China continues to not
supply weapons to the aggressor Russia
we did not openly respond to Germany's
appeal Under Pressure to reassess
Germany's interests in China Joel
stressed that dialogue and partnership
were more important than ever especially
in addressing global warming Lee called
on both Nations to strengthen ties
as two influential powers in the world
China and Germany should work together
more closely to make more contributions
to world peace and development
it was significant that Lee chose
Germany as the first stop on his first
Foreign Tour showing how important the
relationship is for China
while the Chinese Premier spoke about
two economic powerhouses working hand in
hand and side by side Germany Stone was
slightly different while decoupling
economically from China is out of the
question for Berlin the risking has
become the key word to Schultz it means
not putting all his acts in the China
basket by diversifying Germany's
interests to other nations in Asia
Germany's dependency on Russian energy
sources became painfully clear after the
invasion of Ukraine I think one big
issue is certainly is the involvement of
China in major parts of critical
infrastructure it's not just sort of new
Investments but it's also existing
Investments I mean have we really gone
through all of them and made them
fireproof for possible escalation
if things between the U.S and China go
worse I I don't think so and so
Germany's balancing act with China
continues with the country's Industries
hope to expand further in Asia's largest
market amidst Rising political tensions
staff Martin Al Jazeera Berlin